neoliberalism is a term for the
political and economic policies
associated with unrestrained free-market
global capitalism the term was
popularized in the 1980s by Ronald
Reagan Margaret Thatcher and economist
Milton Friedman and is still prominent
today proponents of neoliberalism see
free markets and free trade as a
foundation for human flourishing
creating the most favorable conditions
for individual liberties job growth
technological innovations and
transnational collaborations that
promote peace and global prosperity they
believe that government interference
with free market systems promotes waste
inefficiency and stagnation they reject
regulations on industries high taxation
and public services that are not subject
to market competition and believe in
shrinking the size of government and
restricting its functions to the
protection of private property through
policies and law enforcement the
facilitation of global commerce and the
maintenance of a strong military critics
of neoliberalism argue that neoliberal
policies exacerbate rather than mitigate
economic and social inequalities they
cite the effects of unregulated
capitalism and the reduction or removal
of safety nets typically provided by
governments to support those who are
economically and socially vulnerable
more fundamentally many critics assert
that neoliberalism fails to account for
structural forms of violence such as
systemic poverty racism and other forms
of discrimination they argue that these
hinder equal access to the benefits of
free-market capitalism that neoliberals
imply are universally shared by failing
to acknowledge structural forms of
oppression many Neo liberals assert that
it is individual failings rather than
systemic inequality that lead to social
and
economic vulnerability as with other
political and economic systems religions
function to both support and challenge
neoliberalism
in local national and global context
you